ja komplett ausfall aller anzeigen
während der fahrt auf der autobahn also
inklusive tacho vor mir
plötzliches bremsen aus voller fahrt auf
der autobahn auf einer freien autobahn
abbrechen von überholvorgängen ein
tempomat der eigene entscheidung trifft
das ist schon extrem starker tobak den
ich hier mit meinem modell s von tesla
erleben musste und ich habe die blind
flügel mit video und foto dokumentiert
und der absolute hammer
diese fehler die sind keine einzelfälle
sondern die haben viele zum teil alle
fahrzeuge und tesla scheint davon sogar
zu wissen klicks um science im future
gibt es dreimal pro woche spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal und
aktiviert die glocke nur dann verpasst
er nichts los geht's herzlich willkommen
letzte woche ist mir dann endgültig der
kragen geplatzt schon wieder habe ich
keine antwort aus dem service bekommen
denn schon wieder waren alle displays
inklusive tarot während der fahrt
ausgefallen und danach hatte sich der
tempomat einfach mal selbstständig eine
geschwindigkeit ausgesucht und den wagen
beschleunigt okay ich fuhr im
schritttempo und er sucht die sich so
mir nichts dir nichts 35 kilometer pro
stunde aus aber alleine der umstand dass
der tesla hier selbstständig aktiv wird
das geht ja mal gar nicht aber von
anfang an erst mal elektromobilität ist
hier auf tricks um seien sie um futter
oft thema und hier gibt es eine rasante
technologische entwicklung und immer
wieder fließen neue wissenschaftliche
erkenntnisse in die entwicklung ein aber
es gibt eben auch probleme und die
sollen nicht unter den tisch fallen wir
berichten hier ja immer wieder über die
eco elektromobilität und zwar nicht nur
über die segnung sondern auch über zum
beispiel recycling probleme mit den
akkus ich war jetzt seit 20 jahren
fahrzeuge mit elektroantrieb angefangen
beim ctl sehr sehr cooles gefährt über
den peugeot 106 electric der hatte
übrigens wirklich grauenhafte batterien
prius plug in hybrid und noch ein paar
mehr und das tesla model s das ist
wirklich so die krönung dieser fahrzeug
historie das reichweitenstärkste
elektrofahrrad
der welt jedenfalls serienmäßig mit
einer unglaublichen performance und
technisch extrem weit entwickelt mit
wohl der besten strecken planung
inklusive ladepunkte usw also wirklich
ein hammer auto aber wohl mit ein paar
technischen problemen ich sage mal dass
sich die braker ein fahrzeug das mitten
auf der autobahn heftig bremst oder bei
dem mal eben alle displays ausfallenden
ja das habe ich noch nicht so erlebt und
wenn es nicht so wirklich absolut
beeindruckendes auto wäre hätte ich es
wahrscheinlich schon zurückgegeben wobei
ich war kurz davor und tesla hat schon
eine sehr ich sage mal kreative art
dinge anzugehen
während man bei deutschen
autoherstellern bei der auslieferung
quasi auf den händen getragen wird mit
allem pipapo zuweilen mit enthüllungen
des autors blumen fehlt nur noch der
rote teppich ja ist es bei tesla er so
das gegenteil das ganze findet ihr in
berlin zumindest unter konspirativen
umständen statt einen tesla zu bekommen
das ist schon ein erlebnis
man muss sich das mal angucken das dem
sie die wagen die zur auslieferung
bereit sind und das ganze ist ja auch so
ein logistik gelände also sagen ich
werde hier so mehr paletten an und
abgeliefert und sie soll nur einen mann
dabei tester deswegen muss ich erstmal
hier draußen warten ganz netter
versorgen mich hier im häuschen mit
kaffee und jetzt habe ich ihr der dicke
ja die auslieferung des grauens und auch
solche spuren auf der verkleidung und
kratzer im lack sind bei einem deutschen
autohersteller eher ungewöhnlich aber
sei es drum hier geht es weniger um
atmosphärisches ich fand es eher lustig
als schlimm
auch hier soll es ja um echte technische
probleme gehen und tesla ist ja nicht
gerade dafür bekannt technische probleme
ich sage mal offensiv an die
öffentlichkeit zu bringen thema
fahrzeugbrände eine ganze weile schien
tesla das problem des formel runaways zu
ignorieren also der fall dass wenn eine
zelle in brand gerät was eben auch
spontan ohne außenwirkung zu passieren
scheint wie eine kettenreaktion alle
batteriezellen durch eine
celle durch eine einzige zelle in brand
gesetzt werden das löschen eines testers
dauert deswegen auch immer länger als
bei fahrzeugen mit verbrennungsmotoren
erst als ein fahrzeug in shanghai in
china einer gage von selbst in brand
geriet da reagierte der autohersteller
und modifizierte in die lade software
was aber zu einbußen der
batteriekapazität um rund zehn prozent
führte sprich tesla hat die batterie
einfach weniger vollgeladen dass es
meine kreative lösung die aber in der
folge zu einer klage wegen der
reduzierten reichweite führte in der
folge wurde ein doppelter brandschutz in
die zellen integriert der so genannte
tool interessent methyl lehrer der bei
hitze aufquillt und die zelle von den
anderen zellen thermisch trend heute
gibt es das problem also nicht mehr aber
dafür wohl noch ein paar andere wie es
scheint und was ich ein wenig ärgerlich
finde über manche da wird man erst
aufgeklärt wenn es schon passiert ist
und das ist nicht nur ärgerlich sondern
auch gefährlich dass das modell es in
baustellen nicht gut die spur halten
kann und bei den zahlreichen linien
teilweise etwas durcheinander kommt in
abgaben da kann man ja auch selbst
darauf kommen
das ist nicht ganz leicht ist aber dass
der wagen selbstständig mitten auf der
autobahn heftig bremst bzw verzögert das
ist schon extrem gefährlich vor allem
wenn man davon überrascht wird also
widmen wir uns als erstes mal diesem
problem spontan bremsungen auf der
autobahn
das ist schon ein starkes stück und vor
allem extrem erschreckend wenn das zum
ersten mal passiert aktiviert man den
tempomat dann wird auch immer die
abstands funktion des modells aktiviert
dabei wählt man den abstand manuell am
hebel für den tempomat und den
autopiloten an einem drehknopf wenn man
den hebel einmal zu sich zieht dann wird
der tempomat aktiviert und beim doppel
zug aktiviert sich der autopilot der zum
einen die spur hält und zum anderen nach
betätigen des blinkers automatisch die
spur wechselt und wenn man die
automatische navigation hinzu gewählt
hat auch selbstständig ausfahrten
inklusive blinken und abfahren da muss
man dann selbst nach einigen hundert
metern also am ende der ausfahrt das
steuer über
also so weit so gut funktioniert auch
ganz gut doch zuweilen wird das system
komplett außerplanmäßig selbst aktiv um
bremst ziemlich stark das ist keine
vollbremsung aber eine sehr starke
verzögerung mit dem im zweifel fahrzeuge
hinter einem nicht rechnen
auffahrunfälle drohen das kann im
fließenden verkehr passieren oder auch
komplett freier bahn vor einem wo sich
überhaupt kein hindernis befindet also
genau der seltene fall in dem derjenige
haftet der vorne bremst das wäre dann
dumm gebremst und wenn man sich über
dieses fehlverhalten beschwert dann wird
einem per sms mitgeteilt dass der
autopilot ja eine beta-version wäre und
tesla dieses phänomen bekannt wäre wie
bitte das ist schon ehrlich gesagt ein
ungewöhnlich allerdings passt dieses
verhalten eher zu einer alphaversion
dieser fehler ist viel zu groß und
gefährlich für eine beta version und
zweitens gab es ihn schon als es noch
keine beta version war der mich der
autopilot ist im nachhinein zur
beta-version gemacht worden
wahrscheinlich aufgrund dieser fehler
und drittens passiert es ja auch wenn
lediglich der tempomat aktiviert wurde
und der welt sich dann selbstständig
ohne eigenes zutun einfach eine neue
geschwindigkeit und der es keine beta
software automatisches überholen also
muss man wirklich sagen die autopilot
funktion was in wirklichkeit kein
autopilot sondern eine unterstützung
beim fahren ist dies wirklich sehr
entlassen seitdem ich das modell s damit
fahre trotz aller probleme eher müde ich
nicht mehr auf längeren strecken da man
sich nur noch darauf konzentrieren muss
einzugreifen wenn etwas nicht richtig
läuft also wenn man geschnitten wird
jemand dicht auffährt und so weiter und
sofort zurück zum überholen da ist das
modell es ein wenig kreativ leider das
ganze funktioniert bei den aktuellen
modellen so während der autopilot
aktiviert ist tippt man den blinker in
die richtung an in dem man die spur
wechseln will er checkt mit seinen
kameras die umgebung ab ob sie frei ist
und setzt zum überholen an
hat das schicken allerdings zu lange
gedauert bricht er den vorgang des
spurwechsels einfach ab mittendrin
vollkommen ohne grund doch es gibt einen
grund aber der ist leider nicht
dokumentiert das habe ich erst werden
eine service termins erfahren nach sechs
sekunden wird der vorgang des
spurwechsels abgebrochen was natürlich
extrem blöde ist wenn man schon dabei
ist der komplette
schramm ausfallen das schlägt dem fass
wirklich den boden aus und ich bin
einigermaßen geplättet
nicht nur weil tesla von mir explizit
verlangt mich in weitere gefährliche
situationen zu begeben sondern auch weil
der fehler bis heute noch immer nicht
behoben ist von anfang an bei meiner
ersten längeren tour mit dem modell es
am 22 januar geschah das für mich
unfassbar bei tempo 130 auf der autobahn
fehlen von jetzt auf gleich alle
displays aus alles war schwarz vor mir
im auto und ich teste erst mal ganz
vorsichtig ob der wagen normal fuhr ich
bremste leicht ab und gab wieder gas und
war erst mal beruhigt das modell es
schien normal zu funktionieren
in zukunft sollte ich da allerdings noch
eines besseren belehrt werden nach
einigen minuten kam dann alles wieder
zurück es dauerte wirklich ziemlich
lange bis die displays wieder normal
funktionierten
zurück in berlin rief ich den
technischen support von tesla an die
dann auf den wagen zugriffen aber per
ferndiagnose konnte nichts auffälliges
in den daten festgestellt werden ich
beantragte eine reparatur der termin
wird dann aber gecancelt und ich werde
gebeten daten zu liefern spricht tesla
fordert mich auf so lange mit dem
fahrzeug zu fahren bis der fehler wieder
auftritt okay ich mache das natürlich
mit einem erheblichen bauch kommen denn
eigentlich müsste doch so ein
gefährliches verhalten sofort behoben
werden dann liefere ich tesla die daten
per sms und vereinbare wieder einen
termin allerdings warte ich vergeblich
auf die tester techniker denn manchmal
muss man mit dem test gar nicht in die
werkstatt fahren die kommen angeblich
vorbei angeblich weil ich es bisher noch
nicht erlebt aber denn mit seriöser
weise scheinen meine daten tesla nicht
zu erreichen und dann storniert tesla
den nächsten termin einfach wieder
angeblich bekommt man eine nachricht
aber das habe ich auch noch nicht erlebt
und dann am 13
inzwischen haben wir corona und da wird
schon wieder ein termin storniert obwohl
es ja neben den schwarzen bildschirm
noch andere probleme gibt zum beispiel
eine kamera im linken kotflügel die
immer wieder ausfällt nach fast vier
monaten hin und her reißt mir dann
tatsächlich der geduldsfaden und ich
drohe mit dem rücktritt vom kaufvertrag
und dann geht alles plötzlich ganz
schnell ein werkstattleiter von tesla
kontaktiert mich und ich bekomme ganz
schnell einen termin zwei kameras werden
tatsächlich ausgetauscht und bei der
kamera vorn am kotflügel ist auch
deutlich zu sehen dass die scheibe vor
dem objektiv nicht ordentlich für
hütet wurde allerdings das problem mit
den ausgefallenen displays können sie
nicht beheben weil sie behaupten die
ursache ohne daten nicht eingrenzen zu
können meine anfang des jahres an sie
geschickten daten haben sie nicht
erreicht was wohl an ihrer software für
ihren sms kontakt liegt ob man also ich
soll nochmal daten liefern was ich dann
jetzt auch im juli gemacht habe per mail
keine antwort und auf nachfrage noch mal
keine antwort darauf hin recherchiere
ich jetzt im netz ob ich das einzige
opfer dieses problems bin und ich staune
nicht schlecht ich bin gar kein
einzelfall und der fehler wurde auch
schon behoben aber nur wenn er öfter
auftritt so meine recherche auf reddit
das ist wirklich unglaublich spricht
tesla kennt ganz genau das problem es
ist ein fehler in der mcu der media
control unit ein bekannter
hardware-fehler übrigens nicht zu
verwechseln mit einem problem mit einem
chip wo der speicher kaum noch
ausreichte und immer wieder daten auf
dieselben speicher gruppen gespeichert
wurden deshalb der chip kaputt ging das
ist ein anderes problem aber aus diesem
ganzen lässt sich nur ein schluss ziehen
und der ist wirklich ja ein wenig und
fassbar erstens tesla kennt den fehler
zweitens tesla ihnen aber nur beheben
wenn er öfter auftritt da die mcu nur
mit erheblichen aufwand repariert werden
kann
man muss nämlich das gesamte
armaturenbrett zerlegt werden also
dieser verdacht liegt nahe 3 tesla
laesst sekunden den fehler dokumentieren
aber nicht um ihnen zu helfen
tesla kennt den fehler ja sondern um
herauszufinden wie auch der auftritt das
finde ich wirklich einen absoluten
skandal das fahrzeug ist also nicht
verkehrstüchtig sowie diesmal
interpretieren und tesla belässt den
wagen aber in diesem zustand bisher aus
teslas sicht behoben werden muss ich
gehe davon aus dass die normale reaktion
und vor allem die gesetzmäßige ein
rückruf wäre das kraftfahrtbundesamt hat
auf meine anfrage hierzu noch nicht
geantwortet nicht auszudenken wie so
manche menschen am steuer reagieren
könnten bis zu heftigen unfällen weil
tesla diesen fehler vertuschen will und
die kunden nicht informiert und gleiches
gilt für die phantom bremsung und die
spurwechsel abbrüche drei erhebliche
fehler die so nicht in einem
verkehrstüchtigen auto vorkommen dürfen
würde ich auf jeden fall sagen ich bin
gespannt wie die geschichte ausgeht und
wie die reaktionen sind aus für
verbrennungsmotoren test
das neue super batterie günstiger und
langlebiger als je zuvor
draufklicken anschauen und abonnieren
auch wenn ihr wissen wollt wie diese
geschichte hier weitergeht bis dann
bleibt dran